il y avait de quoi satisfaire les
visiteurs on pouvait trouver de quoi
lire de quoi manger c'est très très bon
enfin là j'ai mangé que les frites pour
l'instant mais mais oui c'est très très
bon ou même décorer son intérieur au
comptoir de Noël au domaine de Madame
Élisabeth à Versailles voilà ça c'est ma
petite dernière c'est une création
autour du Pays-Basque donc on a les
Pyrénées en fond et une vague du
Pays-Basque et j'aime beaucoup cette
association de la mer et de la montagne
c'est un peu l'ensemble des éléments qui
qui laissent rêver s'évader au quotidien
ça fait une jolie déco à la maison 120
exposants étaient présents pour cette 6e
édition ils étaient venus proposer
différents produits et savoir-faire et
80 % d'entre eux étaient ivlinois c'est
un événement pour les ivlinois mais
aussi promouvoir nos artisans donc en
espérant qu'aussi pour ces artisans ça
fasse partie d'une belle renommée à
l'avenir Paris gagnant pour les
exposants mais aussi pour les visiteurs
qui ont pu trouver leur bonheur moi je
suis
émerveillé pour voir la qualité des
échanges que j'ai eu avec ces visiteurs
là et je trouve que c'est une très très
belle initiative que que cette que cet
événement là je reviendrai j'ai beaucoup
aimé le fait qu'il a des choses faites
main qu' a énormément de personnes qui
présentent ce qui font je découvre donc
c'est c'est cool les festivités du
comptoir ont comptabilisé plus de 25000
visites sur les de jours soit 5000 de
plus par rapport à l'année dernière une
réussite pour les organisateurs qui
compte revenir l'année
prochaine